la reunión que duró un par de horas aquí
en el elíseo y fue la ministra quien dio
a conocer lo discutido a lo largo de un
poco más de dos horas en parte de la
idea de esta reunión era la de hacer un
balance del suministro tanto de gas como
de energía de francia explicando que una
de las claves para evitar digamos el
peor de los casos durante este invierno
pues es que haya una movilización a
general en cuanto al abastecimiento ella
explicó que ya las reservas del país
están en un 92% esto se logra dos meses
antes de lo previsto explicó que por
ahora el suministro de gas ruso no está
del todo detenido pero si está en su
nivel más bajo y explicó también que se
le pidió ayuda que es la empresa de
electricidad de francia encargada de las
centrales nucleares que cumpla con el
calendario de mantenimiento de las
centrales porque justamente la mitad de
ellas se están por ahora y no están en
funcionamiento algunas tienen incluso
algunos problemas de corrosión lo que
explicó la ministra es que a partir del
mes de octubre todas las centrales
deberían volver ya a funcionamiento
digamos ya progress vivamente otro de
los puntos discutidos es también la
solidaridad energética a nivel europeo
en especial a francia pues hará un
intercambio de energía y gas con
alemania y también con españa